-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy and Tony Award-winning
actress you know from her work
on "The Good Fight,"
"The Good Wife," and
the "Mamma Mia!" movies.
She is hosting the
Stage & Screen auction
benefiting The Actors Fund
and presented by
Doyle Auctioneers & Appraisers
on Wednesday, April 28th.
Please welcome back
to the show now --
Christine, there's
no audience here,
but you are a star
and I would like you
to walk out like you're
receiving a standing ovation
from a full Broadway theater
Please welcome
Christine Baranski.
[ Majestic music plays ]
[ Light applause ]
[ Laughing ]
They know!
They love you!
[ Chuckling ] They love you.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize she had
a second level down.
[ Laughs ]
Welcome.
I'm so sorry
I can't be a gentleman
and take your hand
and do all the things
that we can do in simpler times.
-You know that bow --
when is the last time
you saw anybody bow?
-You're right.
-There's no performers bowin
anymore.
-No one is bowing,
and yet there's
a bit of a light
at the end of the tunnel.
I think the very fact
that right now
Christine Baranski
is in Midtown Manhattan
is a good sign.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a good sign,
don't you think?
-It's a good sign.
And we've got to bring
Midtown back, you know,
in the bright lights, don't we
My God.
-Yeah.
-It's been a long time.
Remember back when we said
"Oh, my God, they're shuttin
down production for two weeks"
-Mm-hmm.
-Wow.
And then it was, like, summe
and then, "Oh,
we'll be back in the fall,
and here we are.
-Well, the other thing was
it just didn't even seem
feasible
that you could shut down
Broadway for two weeks,
because, as you know,
for someone who's involved
in a show like that, there's
so many people involved.
-There's so many people.
It is a huge community.
I've discovered this,
working with the Actors Fund
that the Actors Fund -- we'r
doing this auction for them --
it helps so many people
and not just actors.
It's everybody involved
in the performing arts.
So, if you think about
who those people are
and that they
have not been working --
we're talking
stage hands, designers,
hair and makeup people,
the people
that take the tickets,
all of the performers --
musicians, singers, dancers --
and, you know, these peopl
have been home.
They've not been able
to go and do what they do.
And you know,
the financial support is just --
been, you know,
a terrible issue for them.
You know,
theater actors and performer
usually work
paycheck to paycheck,
or they don't have big,
you know, bank accounts.
-For anybody who's been
backstage at a Broadway show
or even in the dressing room
of a star of a Broadway show
you realize --
-The dressing rooms
are so small, and
you usually have to climb
many stairs to get
to your dressing room.
And if you're, you know,
a chorus member,
you're scrunched in
with a lot of other people
in the basement
or all the way up.
And, no, their life is hard,
and it's eight shows a week.
And it's not a lot of money,
but to shut it all down
and to have Broadway be dark -
and not just Broadway
but all over the country,
regional theaters,
concert halls --
all of the performing arts
have been affected.
So the Actors Fund
has been amazing.
It's a huge
national organization,
and I think it's given away $2
million for about 16,000 -
$22 million for
16,000 people so far.
And that's everything
from groceries
and helping with rent
and healthcare and insurance
and mental health support.
It's been an enormous lifeline
to people.
-And so this auction is,
obviously, to raise money
for the Actors Fund.
and you're hosting it.
Are you the actual auctioneer?
-Oh, my gosh, no.
I'm not hosting it,
and, God help me, no,
I'm not the auctioneer.
It was my idea last spring
when I came out of the closet,
meaning my own closet,
thinking "Gee,
two weeks off from work?
Why not clean some closets?"
And like so many people,
I was like, "Okay, this is
an opportunity
to get rid of stuff."
And I realized I had
these beautiful
hand-beaded gowns
and, you know, that I'd worn
for award shows or big events,
and I was holding on to them
for, well, sentimental reasons
But they were taking up space.
And I thought, "you know,
if I gave them away now,
maybe to an auction house
or something,
I could make some money."
And then I thought, "I've go
a whole lot of girlfriends
a lot of them
that go by only one name,
who probably have
bigger closets than me
and really some fabulous stuff."
So I started e-mailing,
and then I said, "Why don't we
do this for the Actors Fund.
So, it was Meryl, then it wa
my new girlfriend, Dolly Parton,
with whom I did
a Christmas movie.
And she's the most generou
woman in the world.
So, of course, she is not only
donating a gown
but her mannequin.
-Really?
-Her mannequin, which I want t
bid on the mannequins.
Be like a piece of sculpture
in your living room, right
-[ Laughing ] Absolutely, yeah
-And then we've got Cher,
and then we've got Bette.
And we've got
all the Broadway divas.
We've got Patty LuPone and
Bernadette Peters
and Audra McDonald,
and you know, all of them.
They all said yes immediately.
And then I thought,
"Well, what about the guys?"
So we've got Hugh Jackman giving
his Wolverine leather jacket
from, you know, his movie,
and we've got Steve Martin
an autographed banjo.
And I even had the guts,
because I've been backstag
with him a few times,
to get in touch
with Bruce Springsteen,
who is donating his boots,
a T-shirt, and jeans.
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
-I've just got a whole list.
I mean, we've got
the most amazing -- we've go
Stephen Sondheim wrote out
the first eight bars of
"Broadway baby"
and signed it,
and that's framed.
So, that to me was, like, th
most incredible contribution
And Andrew Lloyd Webber
is donating
a little musical monkey
that was on the set
of the original production
of "Phantom" in London,
and he will personally escort,
whomever bids on his item --
he will personally escort them
into the theater
on the night
"Phantom of the Opera" reopens
-[ Laughs ]
That is quite an escort.
-Then we've got Judy Craymer
producer of "Mamma Mia!"
is donating
my character, Tanya's,
final curtain-call outfit.
And Lorne Michaels --
I reached out to Lorne
and I said,
"Lorne, can you just get m
Tina Fey's e-mail?"
And, of course,
Tina Fey has contributed.
And Lorne said, "Yeah, I hav
a rather big closet from 'SNL.'"
So we've got RuPaul's
opening-monologue outfit,
and we have
Timothée Chalamet's costum
when he played Harry Style
on "SNL."
-That's fantastic.
I thought he was gonna give yo
stuff from the Lorne Michael
personal closet...
-[ Laughs ]
-...which I'm pretty sure is
just like, "I have,
like, a teal polo."
[ Laughter ]
"My summer polo."
-Anyway, does any of this
appeal to you?
-I mean, it appeals to me
a great deal.
-I mean, there's Bryan Cranston,
Alan Cumming,
Victor Garber, John Lithgow,
and then all of these great,
you know, theater actresses --
Laurie Metcalf, Cherry Jones
Andrea Martin, Debra Monk.
It's been tremendous.
People, performers get wha
other performers go through,
and anyone who's done a show
knows how hard it is.
And you know, the people
above the title,
they're not what really make u
the Broadway community.
The Broadway community are
those hardworking people,
particularly the young people.
-I do have a few more question
about that wonderful community
We'll be right back
with more Christine Baranski